and we're live we
are with our incredible backgrounds new
Earth backgrounds let's go let's go
let's
go I love I love the balance in the
backgrounds it's so
perfect it is
beautiful yeah you got the you got the
incredible structures of the
masculine and you have the incredible
softness in the color and the waveforms
of the
feminine and they're just like this is
this is exactly what we're constituting
as like this is the end game it's done
deal end done deal
endgame fullon like this is it like this
is it
like you you find what you're looking
for full emptiness Full Love full Christ
full taking on the collective sin for
transformation and you just die into
this you die into this you die into your
into your Divine unions you die into
your mission for the new world you just
die into it there's nothing left to do
there's nothing left to do that's the
foundation that's where the sword is
striking the ground we're obliterating
all of the Shadow government Tendencies
we're obliterating all of the Shadow
spirituality tend
encies this is a completely distributed
network of new Earth Warriors and
that's that's the vision that's the star
here we
are yes I love that yes yes yes love
that you gave context to the back to the
background it's a symbol for the balance
of the masculine and The Feminine Mother
Earth
with technology yes
exactly yeah
and like the there's nothing better to
do than to just give all of the body to
this that's just the end end of the
story so just give your body fully to it
let God do everything for it and just
live in abundance and prosperity for
everyone infinite basic needs waking up
every day
everything's met instant manifestation
instant creativity un un uh un limited
joy and
peace
like right it's like a personal thing
it's like an invitation for everybody to
internally realize their inner Authority
internally inner yeah and like own their
infinite abundance know that they're
always supported by the godhead
unconditional
love yes yes exactly while striking a
sense of direction and the sermon it's
part of the video too yeah nice right
right like fully sitting in the inner
godhead that everything's you there's no
separation this is this is it and
simultaneously Discerning where there's
still quote Shadow programs that are
running of some sort of one of the one
of the one of the loudest ones is just
control like control Ary basically
whether it's the world economic forum
and Global elitists that are controlling
the entirety of civilization or whether
it's the controlling of minds or bodies
in spirituality uh from this from the
sing from sucking on the testical and
pedestalize the godhead when you
pedestalize done deal done done deal
done deal you do yes so you have to sit
in it yourself fully sit in it yourself
and and completely cut the Outsourcing
completely cut the Outsourcing and then
from from that place then you can work
within this distributed network of these
empty loving Pure Clean mirrors that are
working together to Manifest this new
world like yes yes yes yes that's it
yeah yes yes yes and then we sit in the
joy of that yeah we sit in the joy of
that Joy doesn't need to explain
itself yeah it just is it's a choice
it's an inner
choice and it can look different for
everybody right like the image we have
like how many images of this stomach
it's just like a portion of how it feels
like tap into the texture of how
abundant how how liberating it is to
just stand in your truth as you being
your own Christ you being your own power
and like how can your unique gift
contribute to this
yes
nice how can your unique gift contribute
to this
love it yeah I'm cycling through some of
the the visuals on the solar Punk tab
nice so
beautiful so that's what it is
like this is like a mirror to empower
you to own your unique
frequency in absolute conviction so you
become one of the warrior of new Earth
yes that equally is bringing something
to the table to the building of this
communities yes it's more like Advanced
Consciousness research
centers power yeah it's not like a
community no that it is
highlevel Advanced Consciousness
research centers yes perfect yes because
here here what you're going to have is
you're going to have um a combination of
the most Cutting Edge
science that meets the most Cutting Edge
spirituality and Purity and that those
things are going to come together along
with healing transformation so meaning
whatever work that needs to be done
where this is the this is the big thing
man we're not going to get to where we
want to go like this without going
directly into the traumas and the pains
in the collective body
it just has to be done we can't just say
love and light and then imagine that
that's going to feedback loop into
starving starving people that don't have
access to food or that Border Wars that
have been going on for hundreds of years
it's you you got to go fully into the
pain body of where that border war is
and
fully serve in the transformational way
like these Consciousness research
centers Consciousness Healing Centers
where these quote people from from
places that have had hundreds of years
of dispute can come together and learn
how to hold each other and alchemize the
pain within themselves in their lineages
there isn't another way it has to be
done it has to be done from the
alchemical from the transformational
from the bodily it has to be done like
that so that's that's the type of thing
that we're envisioning in these light
cities is that kind of healing centers
Consciousness research centers The
Cutting Edge of Neuroscience meeting
spirituality all this kind of stuff yeah
nice fck y
yeah I love the pain body because that's
the relevance of what's Happening Now in
the quantum jump to these new world
cities as you mentioned we need to be
fully willing to look at the Shadows we
need to be fully willing in humility to
own whatever up and accept our Humanity
as well as our Divinity like yes we all
have access to swords and the godhead
yet we all have a human body so like the
long-term vision is there's no teachers
there's no students it's just everybody
in the absolute merge Perfection of
divinity and the human self perfect
yes let's go let's go I love that I love
that that oh yeah remember the absolute
and complete dead end to all planetary
sing oh
yes yes
so anything can be simping it's simping
it's in other words giving your power
away to any sort of authority out of
your own wounds and not believing in
your absolute nature as an aspect of God
every everybody is an aspect of God it's
not like oh I am the omnipresent God and
everybody else is just like a ghost no
it's everybody's an aspect of the
godhead working in interconnected
balance so no giving your power away to
any type of
government yes that's it yes any
Authority whatsoever yeah simping is all
about Outsourcing yeah exactly
and um it's the end of that I love what
you said there about like it's a
complete uh complete
constitutionalization complete Clarity
around this is the godhead this is the
source embodied in a unified Network
called Earth called New Earth and
there's zero sing zero sing No
Outsourcing whatsoever full power full
Power full power
Direction full Direction
and also full beautiful surrender into
the Divinity of the colors and the
textures and the embodiment and all of
that so it's just it's just too simple
really I keep coming back to how simple
like the quote like Pinnicle code is and
it is just this it really is just this I
mean everybody knows it that's why it's
all about remembering it because it's
just covered by all kinds of layers of
nonsense and conditioning um um and so
it's literally
remembering that this is what we're here
to
do yeah I love that you mentioned
surrender yeah it goes back to it all
goes back to relationships so like the
baby step to this is healing the
relationship between the masculine and
The Feminine will and
surrender
yeah
yeah freedom and
love yeah it's so simple it's like
that's it that's all
it there's nothing to say now like
everybody
everybody done it's it's funny I was
just about to say okay that's the end of
the episode yes we're done there's
nothing else to
say all in complete what now
yeah
oh
[Music]
wow what's what's really exciting is
that there's a there's a magnet around
this sword
that's
that's that's divinely placed in the in
the earth that then radiates out this
magnet magnetic
field called New
Earth and it's fascinating because that
magnet itself is such an attractor to
those that are already feeling within
themselves the godhead they're feeling
completeness within themselves they're
feeling themselves as the totality
they're feeling themselves as Christ as
giving themselves fully to the
collective transformation so that is
literally the magnet that is the magnet
and then there's a gravitation to that
portal the magnet is a portal it's a
gravitation to that portal you're you're
being invited through this content and
through more content to come you're
being invited into that portal for this
for this and for your gift within
this yes unique authentic
frequency
yeah than where do you feel that people
can be limiting themselves into not
owning their authentic
power well the first thing that was
coming up when you were talking about
what how we're limiting what the the
main way is that we just we just don't
believe that this is that this is what
we we're here to
do yeah so we just we just we don't we
don't wake up fully constitutionalized
as this and
so yeah we just leak we leak the
conditions leak conditionings leak uh
all kinds of godhead power and all kinds
of um remembering that this is
actually this is actually it this is
this is the most be literally what's
happening is you're being asked to
remember what is the most beautiful
thing imaginable that's what you're
being asked to remember W that's that's
potent yeah wow it's like asking
everybody what is the most beautiful
thing imaginable for you like their
unique Vision it's like we're not The
Visionaries we're holding the space for
you the audience to be on your unique
frequency as an equal co-creator and
merge into the field of I am my own God
like everybody is but yes yes yes yes
yes because here's another another way
to to to say that is that here you see
the beautiful um our uh what's coming
through Us in terms of what the most
beautiful thing imaginable
is so here it looks like these
incredible biomimic like mushroom towers
that are in perfect technology in nature
and then for you there's this incredible
wavy Garden of Mother Earth with all of
her flora and fauna you know and so
so for each one that's listening there's
going to be your version of that but
your task is to just simply hear this as
a reflection to yourself to
remember what is the most beautiful
thing
imaginable from that unique godhead what
is yeah yeah yeah let's go let's go
let's go
everybody so like it can look like
anything for you and for you I mean the
audience like anything
like it's like imagining yourself in one
of these mushroom Towers in your own
room personalized office doing the thing
that lights you off it's about you it's
about your unique sense of Freedom your
heart expansion your
joy oh I love it okay so as you're
saying that I'll go ahead and describe
things that were coming up for mine it's
like all right so so I have like within
what you were just describing as like
your own unique space in that mushroom
Tower or whatnot it's like I got my I
got my sparring gloves so I'm going out
and I'm sparring and I'm really taking
good care of the body I'm sparring you
know we're having a lot of fun just kind
of getting you know getting into that
together you know with the other the
other really constituted Divine
masculine that's there and then um and
then I'm going you know I'm going to
this like like like this really
beautiful like um switching between like
super
cold like even Beyond ice bath and like
cryo cryotherapy and I'm going boom
right into like the hot the hot hot
hotness you know space and then so
that's kind of priming the body for then
like taking gorgeous you know gorgeous
shower just overlooking Everything clean
clean clean okay cool then I'm in my
workspace you know and then I can like I
can just snap whatever I want as like Bo
like as my like badass
elegant clothing you know like Snap like
whatever I want snap
yeah and now I'm in my like
badass workspace that's like some sort
of perfect Spa like spatial AI you know
so I can work in the spatial AI That's
also like connected to my actual
creative process and thinking process
and so I'm using my my thoughts and my
creativity to just perfectly move around
data and information into creative
catalysts that are then sent out across
our network of new Earth and then you
know do that for a while and then you
know we you know again just like Snap
like whatever you know little little
nice tea tea meeting you know have some
tea have some coffee whatever to eat
little bit little bit of food whatever
snack you want then you're you know
you're going down and you're like going
out into like one of the new projects
that's being built and you're doing like
a site visit at one of the new energy
projects that's being built some free
energ project that's being built down
there and you're like doing a little
site visit down there you're you know
you had your like incredible like parrot
and and dog or whatnot come with you on
the
journey down there so you got like your
you're rolling with your squad your
animal Squad like on the way down then
you do that and
then and then you like you have
something planned in the evening like
together where like you know it just
came you know it just came through like
hey like like would you would you like
to be invited to this Gathering of you
know your 15 closest people where you
guys are coming together around fire for
music andjoy and dance and and play and
all kinds one of those in one of those
round nature spots nice yes yes
yes and there's like a waterfall inside
of it wow yeah love it kind of to again
down into the ones that are
on the how you call them the ones that
wear the circle inside like a pyramid in
the oh domes oh yeah those ones
cool yeah yeah
nice all right so so so your turn
describe your
day we're going to have these machines I
mean the greatest machine machine is
your body you don't need an external
machine to heal your nervous system so
that's my gift I can help anybody heal
their nervous system with my nervous
system yet I'm going to also create
machines so I don't have to exhaust my
body so I'm going to have like different
ESP special it's like imagine just like
an avatar you get inside of this thing
and you completely recharge your whole
cellular memory and nervous system and
you get like a complete activation at
morning and at night so you're never low
energy and you don't need people for
energy you have your own pot where you
recharge consistently and it aligns your
energy
centers amazing
[Laughter]
yes that's during the day and then at
night I have this epic woman's Circle in
one of those like nature
Towers
yes I like how you bring up like The
Pinnacle of uh biomedical technology I
love that and uh like full spectrum
chakri activation of all body centers
like constantly I love that huge huge
fan of that that's
beautiful it's so necessary I mean I I'm
like overflowed with sessions I can only
not multiply myself so much to be that
mirror so people can like heal their
centers I mean ideally in 10 years from
now quote unquote No time whenever this
gets fully
crystallized then there's so many other
beings that are stepping into their
roles as healers through each other or
perhaps there's not even need to heal so
these machines are just a way to just
keep your system in
Balance all the time exactly it's just
free energy free sharing and everybody's
gift has equal value exactly that's the
exchange yeah yeah
in imp impenetrable
alignment unwavering
alignment impenetrable alignment
yes like you're always yeah in
unconditional love Bliss Joy ecstasy
there's not even a need for discernment
because there's no Shadows like at this
point we have casted out all the shadow
governments I love that in the spiritual
communities there's no need for a
spiritual Community because that's
everything is
spiritual this is the merge of the
material with the spiritual because now
there's no corruption and everything is
in authenticity there's T I mean I live
there I communicate telepath
telepathically with everybody in my
field that I give access to I do shut
the door sometimes so be
cautious yet at this point everybody
would have developed their own telepathy
so there's no secrets we don't even need
to speak we just like communicate
with with God because nobody is scared
to hide anything so like everybody
activates their telepathy that it's
always there for you if you want
it
yes wow I love casting out all Shadow
that's so powerful oh my
gosh oh boy oh girl
yeah casting out all Shadow love
it like pure Pure Radiant authenticity
um
gosh like what everybody what everybody
wants casting out
corruption ooh so good all corruption
all of it
just hope corruption yeah g yes yes a
full planetary clearance of corruption
love
it love it it so how can people
individually start into that for
somebody watching that's like oh I want
to start individually to obliterate
corruption within my own
field yeah well of course realization of
what one truly is first and
foremost yeah and
then and then
activating in the frequency of clearing
the corruption in the collective nice
not being passive like activating their
true voice and stepping up for truth yes
yes exactly
yes
nice yep stop consuming content and sing
on everybody yeah and I want to go back
to this yeah this is why I call my
podcast Tru porn because I want all the
beings that s into porn and like those
only fan girls to go to my only God L
fans I'm like a troan horse because I
want the best for you like that's just a
symbol to pick at your ego so you're
like stop wasting your life force in
something that's nonsense and actually
receive the codes if you have the
humility and Grace to receive them and
then apply them and go on the field and
play Like a Warrior like in stage just
like I'm GNA watch Netflix do your
own movie of Netflix in your own
life yes
nice nice yeah I love that Ian horse as
I've been talking about like pulling
people by their genitals from behind
only fans and onto the new Earth scene
into realization onto the new Earth
scene you're just describing the exact
Trojan Horse of that yeah is like okay
only God fans yeah exactly like get in
get in here and activate
within activate within no leakages no
Outsource ing no leaking stop leaking
leaking everywhere man everywhere is
leakage everywhere it's crazy it's crazy
it's all kinds of leakage and like the
quote the collective Hive algorithm has
yet to quote pick up the pheromonal
signature of what we're putting down so
from a quote like a mathematics or
artificial intelligence computer science
perspective even biology what what's
being said is that what we're pointing
to is a Global maximum whereas right now
we're stuck at a local maximum you see
so the little ant hiive or beehive of
the collective is like circling for food
and resources around the local maximum
and what we're doing through our content
through our new Earth portal is we're
generating Catalyst at that local
maximum to then create the Alchemy the
transformation for the bees and the Ants
aka the humans to start moving more more
and more towards holy look at this
Global
maximum but it takes energy it takes
resources it takes alignment it takes
death it takes death of the local
maximum to move to the global maximum
you have to completely detach from all
of those Matrix Systems from all of the
uh you have to sell your your your time
for money to pay for your basic needs
you have to you have to detach
completely from all of those things see
that they serve very good very good but
now we're moving on to this Global
maximum and it's this
constitutionalization into an allocation
of energy and resource and everything
into that Global maximum and so that's
how to say it from a CS AI mathematics
bio perspective that's you know it's
really relevant for us Geeks like I'm a
geek like I'm a nerd I'm a dork 100% so
you know I relate to you science and
engineering peep so deeply I've
interviewed hundreds and
hundreds of you in all of your different
fields and so um this is this is my way
of communicating to you with love that
we need you fam we need
you we need you you are our new Earth
Systems Engineers you are incredibly
brilliant Geniuses but you're still kind
of not polarizing you're still not fully
aligning into that so there's still
something that's um and this is what
we're opening up through our our new
Earth portal we're opening up we're
opening up for you the ability to align
into that and to activate your own gifts
for that and so that's we'll get into
that more you know in the coming weeks
and whatnot and it'll be really exciting
to kind of open up that that that portal
yeah for these Brilliant Minds
yeah yeah so good I'm so so good
I love when you mention to everybody you
are needed like you are needed to be
part of this with your unique gift it's
like yes fuing fun like any sense of
wounded unworthiness that you have it's
bro or sister
like you have something so so like your
unique signature of your
soul and where there's no energy
leakages and you have energy Mastery and
focus that's when you can Excel so those
are the gifts that get activated in
these portals that are going to be
co-created so then you're constituted to
become one of this H hyphens hens
countes co-creators for what's for
what's happening I mean it's here one
day we just open the door it's right
there everybody got a line F yes
yes yes
yes so I love how you uh bring us to
that it's like we're just reflecting
back at the godhead itself to shatter
the limits that are holding back that
unique signature gift and that's so
exciting cuz it's it's such a diverse
variety of gift just like it's the
diverse variety of of nature itself so
that's what that's what we really are
excited about being activated and I want
to add one one more thing to the that
new Earth portal moving from the local
maximum to the global maximum is that
it's also about getting those that have
a good amount of wealth that have
especially ACR wealth in an ethical way
but that are still seeking or even if
unethical but that want to do their own
karmic Alchemy and purification and
whatnot but it's about really moving
that wealth in into the global maximum
and this new Earth portal is like your
way to move the wealth and alchemize the
wealth into these mushroom towers and
these mother earth Gardens you know
that's that's what's being you know and
into these conscious Healing Centers
this is what's being
said oh wow that's so well articulated
yes and I love that you touched the
point of karma through the money because
that's a lot of the work I do with my
wealthy clients that have even if you
have had a wealth in a way that's not
integrous there is an opportunity for
you to heal your karma and clean that
money by becoming constituted in service
to others and offer some of that to
create these cities that are not only
going to benefit you yet the whole at
life yes yes yes yes gosh that's that's
so so good it's so so good and it's
fascinating because it's like as as that
wealth Silo opens up it is
um it both um it makes you more selfless
which is I love that part of it actually
as it as that wealth Silo opens up and
it funnels into this Global maximum of
new Earth what's happening is that the
selfish greedy corrupt scripts are being
alchemized just by that itself
so the the purification of Consciousness
back to its innocent God head nature is
happening through that process like it's
almost like you're being asked as those
that have succeeded monetarily at the
local maximum to Now open up
and help help Mo help us move to the
global maximum through this portal and
go through this divination basically
it's an initiation into complete
divination um and that's what's that's
what's being being offered cuz you may
think that divination is you know oh it
is my my uh my wealth Silo and all of
this stuff but everyone knows it's
unfulfilling everyone knows because
everyone's been there we've run those
programs we've run those scripts and we
know that it's inherently unfulfilling
and the entire day is full of
unfulfillment and of trying to get
fulfillment through something else acre
more wealth or getting luxurious objects
or sexualizing and objectifying or
substances or travels or whatever
endless endless endless
and that that thing is running inside
all the time even if there's lots of
wealth and so what what we're what we're
hinting at is at this Global maximum
that very thing that's running inside
that's constantly dissatisfied and
unfulfilled is
gone
[Music]
gone get to be liberated empowered in
passion and a philanthropist for the new
Earth yes and perhaps clear off who
knows 10,000 lifetimes of karma in the
way yeah which I love that you speak to
it in a scientific engineer way because
I love that about our balance in sharing
these new Earth codes like well Karma
and then anybody watching like what's
that how would you express that in a
scientific
way
um probably something to do with with
the the the oif of energetic
patterns yeah so like like the the oifc
of energetic patterns that then keep
cycling cycle cycle cycle cycle cycle
and then there has to be a uh a cycle
cycle cycle cycle cycle cycle yeah yeah
yes yeah so contracted in Loops of pure
choices and decisions that promise
happiness that perhaps were
were created in a non- integrous way to
just receive that object of quote
unquote fulfillment so now it's an
opportunity to self forgive remove any
type of Shame guilt or contraction into
that or perhaps
the it's all greed and pride isn't it
like that's what it comes
to to open that up into givingness and
humility and unconditional love and
support of the whole while also keeping
your unique gift in your creation of
your wealth and perhaps then you realize
that whatever it is that you started
doing that generate you the world at the
beginning it's not your true Essence
then you're like nice maybe I want
something
else yeah
nice yeah exactly exactly something
that's way more activating and radiant
and luminous and true yeah it's
beautiful yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah oh man yeah it's like um we the
gaining awakeness or awareness or
insight into those solidification of
energetic patterns and how to create the
liberations or the expansions or the
Alchemy of the healing into something
that is more of the totality and also
more of the godhead within and the
uniqueness of it and all of that is is
just like that's our that's our new
Earth portal here that's what is being
is being offered
yeah and good yeah and the perfect
balance of the masculine and feminine
Dynamics all of your relationships in
complete
Harmony that's where also fulfillment
lies in being activated in your heart's
fashion and also having nourishing
relationships yeah so that's part of
healing
process alchem Al Alchemy yeah that goes
on inside the
portals what needs to heal in which of
your energy centers so you can start
beaming true love start
beaming authenticity start beaming
humility start beaming Direction start
beaming
just getting like a sensation like all
your energy centers is fully open and
bursting in light that's the image I get
like and then there's no need to chase
anything or seek anything not even
Enlightenment you are the enlightenment
itself yeah and then you you are aligned
with the soul frequencies Soul friends
Soul people Soul
collaborators that are already in that
reality playing playing with you in that
high frequency
field yes something like that yes yes
yes I say something like that because
instead of words I get cuton candy and
like roses and I'm like how do I
translate the image that godhead gives
me cutting candy and roses and I'm like
how do I find words for this let me let
me see if I can if I can translate a bit
so um okay so imagine that the um the
all all all bodies are made of sunlight
and then that sunlight is um has a quote
like a unique way of energetically
expressing itself
creatively
so the foundation is that all of it is
sunlight and then the frequencies that
come together for the unique energetic
creative creativity the flowers the
rainbows the cotton candies yeah
[Laughter]
yeah oh so and then using the best uh
technology in perfect harmony with
nature for
for for play for play and for creativity
and for joy and um service service
exactly yeah
yeah and I love that you said the
perfect harmony with nature because the
reason there's an imbalance of not what
you can see in Atlas background that is
when the feminine it's in her divine
power and when the masculine is in his
divine power as well without any wounds
like when you go you see a society where
there's just pure buildings and they
destroy Mother Nature that's the wounded
masculine that's the little kid being a
tyrant destroying Mother Earth and then
if this just nature mother earth also
wants to play with the Divine masculine
so the background is just the symbol of
Perfect Harmony of the masculine and The
Feminine in Holy Trinity the mother and
father of the mother and father and the
child which is just your passion in your
heart in alignment with that in perfect
security security safety infinite safety
infinite resources infinite love
Infinite Wisdom it's just
perfected yes yes nice wow I love that
it's fun way that's a fun fun way to to
put it is like the H the Holy Trinity as
the mother and father as these
backgrounds and the child as the unique
creative gift radiating through but it's
all in Perfect Balance too in Perfect
Balance so so for example if if the
if if it's too tight and too conditioned
in just um the masculine it won't be
able to recognize the feminine it won't
be able to recognize your background for
example so
and as you described it it's like that
the the wounded masculine that just
destroys kilom square kilometers in the
thousands of rainforests on Earth just
to just to do whatever shortterm
short-term behaviors has no um uh
calibration to
long-term um seven Seventh Generation
indigenous principalities has no no
calibration to that whatsoever but then
when it's B balanced with that when the
Divine masculine is balanced with that
then we're talking about we have
emergences of things like what's in this
background and and even Beyond in all
kinds of flavors but then you know
there's also the the the mother that is
able to really get tuned
into the balance within herself again
the the
contractivity
that's a way to put
it so by unwinding the
contractivity what you can do is you can
feel the balance nature within the
godhead itself of both polarities and
then you can step from that place and
integrate from that space into your
expansiveness of your embodied polarity
itself but in perfect balance and in
Divine Union also and and sexual honor
and familial honor and
and and honor with with with the with
the new Earth and the mission and all of
those things but again it's like from
from the from the mother it's like
seeing it's like being able to see
within
herself the beauty of the masculine
creativity uh and systems so it's just
it's just like that I mean it's
basically these two these two
backgrounds um fully felt inside as the
godhead fully felt inside in perfect
balance and then taking your integrating
that into your You Know Your Role your
unit gift yeah yeah I love that you
mentioned that we need each other
everybody like it's if a woman
is like I'm hyper independent or a man
is like I can do it all with a woman we
need each other we need to be in balance
with the feminine and the masculine so
the only reason that's not in complete
full alignment in this now this moment
because it chips in the next second it
is in alignment now nice so from that
end coming from the
end I love
it then what do you need to heal within
yourself what is the fear what is the
prevention that as a man hasn't allowed
you to fully trust the mother within you
it's not a process outside when you heal
your own inner feminine your own inner
mother then you will see reflected in
your reality the perfect calibration of
the feminine that is Meant To Be Your
Divine Union or your counterpart for
this how you call them F familial
systems
yes
nice or in the other end as a woman when
you heal your inner masculine you become
your own inner Authority your own inner
father then there's no projection
there's no blame there's no hurt there's
no
trauma then you see the reflection of
the perfect
masculine and then alchemizing that both
of the masculine gifts systems
engineerings and the motherly gifts the
feminine Gifts of nourish M and support
and love
nature together in
harmony tomorrow I open my eyes you're
yeah
yes right right it's like yeah the your
spot on that the The Liberation of the
limits that are making that contraction
are the very thing that also um and also
sitting in the constitutional ization of
the most Divine creative Force which is
the sexual energy of God it's the most
Divine creative Force everything is sex
we talk about all the time the universe
itself is sex god having sex with itself
these words are are going through the
microphone and into the into the ears
Across The Ether and each word is sex
it's it's sex it's sexing with all of
the structure of ideas that are on the
receiving end yeah and then it's
birthing a new quote you see
alignment yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah another word for it it's sex um
sexual sacred energy exchange so
everything it's a sacred energy exchange
that's the beauty of energy Mastery no
leakages Focus Direction
nourishment it's just beyond words yes
yes and the the whole reality field also
morphs to that alignment I love that
sacred energy Exchange it's such a
perfect acronym for sex also I love that
and the whole thing is that so if if at
the root there is a ceiling and a
constitutionalization at the root of
sexual honor the entire reality field
morphs around that so when you're
constituted for your Divine Union only
and it's written all over the spiritual
and Mystic and religious traditions in
these ancient wisdoms that
do not just leak the sexual life force
all over the place really really hone in
really seal that really seal that and
and and and and be honed in and tuned
into the Divine Union
frequency because that's where that's
where God is going to reveal itself so
profoundly so profoundly to you and and
so like that's where also all of these
codes all of these these new ways of of
seeing and being and being activated
it's like you think that you can find
the
most uh
exhilarating and
fulfilling
experiences in all kinds of things but
really you find them from this ceiling
of sexual honor Divine unions creativity
morphing the entire reality field around
that sitting in the godhead like a king
and queen so powerfully so powerfully
and reflecting back at other Divine
unions the king and queen in the godhead
there without any sort of spiritual
Shadow hierarchical
projections yeah it's just
like yeah
and
then back to how this is an inner
process this is something that first
there's an invitation for your
individual journey in marrying your own
masculine and feminine
polarity yes yeah nice that's so good so
good got marry yourself keep going keep
going it's so
good my God
you got to marry yourself first and
that's also the beauty of these portals
like
besides opening up the space for the
beings that want to contribute with
their
wealth besides healing the karma of how
that monetary energy was
co-created there's also the opportunity
for them to heal that unbalanced wounded
masculine that was like go go go just
make money just this into marrying their
inner feminine so they can be
constituted in the newer Vision yes yes
yes yeah okay so two things there one is
that
like um by fully sitting in the godhead
first in Perfect
Balance then constituting as the sexual
honor piece and warping the reality
field to the Divine union now the
fascinating thing is when you sit in it
fully what happens is it's it's obvious
that the the other side of the godhead
appears and it's like
aha Aha and so it's wholeness or like
pure fulfilled
godhead pure fulfilled godhead like the
most Pinnacle of fulfillment imaginable
coming together with the other one that
is most Pinnacle fulfillment imaginable
in complete wholeness of godhead and
then that's where it's there's there's
no quote codependencies or whatever all
all those kinds of
um all those kinds of issues trauma
bonds all that kinds of stuff so
it's it's so important to first and
foremost go completely on one's own
complete emptying freeing loving
balancing and then it appears it appears
itself God Appears itself to relate to
itself in the Divine Union from that
comp from that Indescribable it's so
there's that and then the second thing
was the second thing you were saying
um the go go go Mas yes thank you yes so
so it's so it's so beautiful that
um that we that we we know deep within
the wounded masculine we deeply know
that one of the most important things
for us is to
learn what the healed what the healing
of that is and what the balancing is
with the feminine and it's fascinating
how many times that it comes up like men
learning how to hold other
men it's just so important it's like
it's like I don't if you know how to
like hold other men and for men to hold
you like in love in Brotherhood in
Embrace but you also know how to put on
your sparring gloves and like spar with
your brothers and like and like get
active activated like that and like love
like if you can if you can do the
warrior and the that kind of like
feminine love with your with your Divine
Brothers if you can do both of those
you're going to be unstoppable
Unstoppable truly truly in the Divine
masculine and I and I guess it's also
clearly mirrored over there in the
mother and in the feminine yeah so you
you like learning like like for example
for you you love the energetics of of
business which is amazing yes yes yes
yes I'm all old business
baby but
also I love being my
feminine I love relaxing I love
nourishing I love giving I love that it
has to be
both at least for through I explored
every single configuration of
Consciousness so I'm like but it feels
more fulfilling it's being constituted
in both
so there's nothing that you need outside
of yourself that's the thing you become
whole and complete and then you become
like this Beacon of light that outpour
and radiates out outwards and that's
abundance that's infinite Prosperity
that's that's the infinite basic needs
and more like infinite basic needs is
those towers with yes the motherly
circles is that just basic needs that's
Heaven that's like everything
yes yes yes
yes yes
nice and what what used to be the
the the wounded mascul
in separation and in anxiety and in
panic do do do do do do do must get
worthiness must get worthiness um or
must get women's validation must get
woman's validation yeah exactly must get
Daddy mommy's validation Etc same
singinging simp simp
simp endless things to S on
yeah oh boy okay so so what that was
more like the the wounded masculine the
past of it and now if you look at like
these buildings and what not in infinite
basic needs abundance where this is
coming from now is it's coming from not
the the place of oh that building is
going to have my last name on it or
whatever right that's where that's where
the wounded masculine would come from it
would be like this is my dick
look at my dick in the air it's so damn
big it's bigger than all your dicks you
know that kind of thing it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah who's up on the top
100 on the Forbes billionaires list look
at that look at that you know simp on me
bro s on me
yeah exactly s on me yeah it's like
calling call it the beacon of s on me um
so so instead of instead of that
what what what we're talking about with
this infinite basic needs abundance
we're talking about a um a da a
decentralized autonomous organization
called Earth a distributed network of
divine unions new Earth Warriors we're
talking about that and from that what
happens is it's everything's owned by
everybody it's owned by nobody and
everybody it's owned by Consciousness
everything's owned by The Singularity
it's infinite basic needs abundance so
at any point you can be like mushroom
Tower magic boom snap fingers manifest
like there's your you know you're like
okay well how about one over here like
this in more of a nature by a river or
whatever boom little like little Dome
structure over there by the river that
you know it's like all different kinds
of of uh but there but you see when it
doesn't come from lack it's like you
always have what you need you're always
at the source of infinity you're at the
source of infinite abundance and basic
needs and instant manifestation and so
it's not out of lack that I need I need
I need I need I need I need I
need it's it's out of like Divine
creativity and like oh like let's see
what that's like and then everything's
also everything's also like recycled and
and because everything's Pure Energy
everything's Pure Energy being recycled
into exactly what is to be manifest at
that time and so um so you'll you'll
you'll see that that's the frequency
that this new Earth vibration of the
healed masculine where where comes from
it comes from that that distributed
place where it's it is completely dead
yet radiantly alive and that it's in a
perfect distributed harmonic where it's
like serving its Divine unions it's
serving its its family it's serving its
children it's serving the new Earth it's
serving as Christ taking on all of the
collective sin for transformation of
pain of wounding of instant
manifestation and pure energy with
science and engineering it's taking all
of that on because it's completely
completely ignited um fully fully with
all of that I mean that's the that's the
sword that's in the in the ground here
and that's the magnetic field in the
portal that is that is and The Feminine
so badly wants to be magnetized into a
portal like that and into the Divine
unions that can come through that with
healed balanced masculines cuz then it
gets to finally be a part of something
that's Transcendent and gorgeous and and
balanced and beautiful where it can come
alive as it's Natural Essence it's so
perfect it's so well said come alive as
the Natural Essence and also because the
masculine is so heal it feels safe to
surrender in its in its softness and
Trust the Divine
mother so then inequality and balance
supporting each other in the consistent
celebration that life
is yes like life is a party ruined by
the separate self ruined by the egos
ruined by control ruined by the fear
without ego control fear I mean healthy
ego like create your ideal heart's
frequency yeah it's not ego it's like
you're the embodiment of your soul yeah
yeah
exactly I what else nothing else yeah it
is it is a celebration that's the the
essence of the essence of what is being
said is that the the the feminine the
mother is like the celebration on Earth
of all of the nature color texture dance
light explosion fireworks cotton candy
rainbows all that stuff flowers and then
the masculine is the space it's the
space the freedom the Stillness the
distributed that manifests the new Earth
Systems and space of basic needs
abundance and whatnot that then allows
this create celebration to be
like the infinite peaceful blessful
party yay y yeah
you can be a geek you can be a nerd you
can create your whatever nness in one of
your towers and also at the same time
you know that every single woman in the
new Earth is so fulfilled and
their power and their Essence and their
like FL flowerly self so you get out of
like your whatever your your system
engineering L and then like everyone's
like hi like let's play and then it's an
infinite play of Joy love freedom and
abundance
just Jing Jang in order that's it
yes we literally just hit an hour on the
dot like yeah episode complete I think
we're I think so too I think that was
just
like
okay okay and anybody felt the yes
calling for one of these containers feel
free to email me 121212 portal and the
email below on the email below and all
right so there's plenty links there's uh
Nicole's email below for that portal
there's uh her Instagram and YouTube to
go check out her content there there's
also the website link below my website
link where you have that solar Punk that
we were looking at earlier um this so
you can go and use that again as your uh
as your archetypal vision and
actualizing your unique gift um so you
can use that we also have the home Dow
link below so that's the mechanism that
we're using to decentralize basic needs
into Infinite abundance for all so go
and check that out we have a whole
beautiful light paper there that's that
already has hundreds of millions in
assets under management that's moving
forward in that direction to build these
light cities to build this so get
involved in that and um stay tuned for
more new Earth portal content because
more of that is coming and it's coming
in all different kinds of expansions of
contractions it's coming in all
different kinds of magnetism to portal
into to then get godhead activated and
um
and also to uh containers containers
there also like a little uh like Mario
boost on Rainbow Road
just oh so all kinds of cool stuff like
that the new Earth Warrior Network
coming together through that also so
stay tuned for that and
um um oh yeah with the video of course
if it brought you value give it a like
comment below with your thoughts on the
episode subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet share it with those that you
feel like resonate with this frequency
so share it and that's all infinite love
Infinite love and activation let's go
let's
go okay thanks everyone for tuning
in